-Do you feel the love
out there?!
-I do!
[ Laughs ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you. Thank you.
-Oh, my gosh.
Please. Thank you.
Thank you so much.
God, they love you. We love you.
-I love you.
-Thanks for coming back
to the show.
-Yeah.
-I didn't even know
if you were going to come back
after last time.
-Yes.
-We did "Hot Ones" on the show.
-That's right.
I was very upset with you.
-Yeah, you were really --
-I was so mad.
-The last time I saw you,
you were, like --
I think you were vomiting
in your dressing room.
-Yes.
You came in like, "You good?"
I'm like, "No.
Get out of my room!"
-It was so funny.
I told you backstage,
but I really mean this.
I watched you during COVID.
You did "Selena + Chef."
And, man, if you don't love
Selena Gomez in --
Like, if you can't love her
any more, watch this show.
You were so charming
and cool and fun.
I just loved it.
-Basically, I was an idiot.
-No, no, you were so fun,
and I loved it.
And I go, "Oh, that's just you
being fun and cool."
I just absolutely loved it.
I just wanted to say that.
And then, I don't think I've
talked to you since
"Only Murders in the Building."
-Right.
-It's my favorite.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's the best show.
-Yeah.
-It's the best show.
-I had so much fun.
Working with Steve and Marty --
it's honestly a dream.
They're incredible.
-Did you meet them before
you did the show?
-No. I didn't.
-You just got cast in it.
-Yeah. No, I actually met with
them before I got the part.
-Yeah.
-And are they
rubbing off on you?
-Oh, completely.
I've become
snarky and a little grumpy.
Little grumpy.
-Yeah.
-No, they're just the best.
-They are two of the funniest
human beings on Earth.
-Yeah.
And are you shooting Season 3?
-Yeah, we start in January.
-You do? Alright, good.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I know -- You were
telling me backstage --
You were like, "Oh, yeah,
you do this thing."
And sometimes, I go,
"They just joke all the time."
-Yes.
-Yeah.
And sometimes you go, "Yeah,
I'm going to roll by eyes."
-Oh, completely.
Are you kidding me?
I'm trained to roll my eyes
at both of them.
They are so funny
and they just --
They'll tell the same jokes
every now and then.
It's kind of like,
"Alright, guys."
-Yeah, but then -- Yeah.
And then you just
said something,
and Marty Short
had a joke about Meryl Streep
and you got to meet
Meryl Streep.
-Yeah, she came over
to the table.
-So -- And you freaked out.
-Oh, my gosh.
I looked like
I was going to cry.
-Yeah.
Because it's Meryl Streep.
-It's Meryl Streep.
-Yeah, she has that
effect on people.
-Yeah, you think?
-Yeah, she does.
But -- And you never met before?
-No. She grabbed my hand
and she kissed my hand.
I was like, "Oh, my God!"
-We have a picture.
I wanted to show this.
-Oh, God!
-She grabbed your hand here.
And I go, "That's cool."
I had to show this.
And then here's --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah. Look at this.
Come on!
-I'm so happy.
-I know you're so happy.
-How great is that?
-It was such
a surreal moment, honestly.
You could only dream of,
you know,
meeting her
or working with her, you know?
-Yeah, exactly. She's a star.
-Yeah.
-Speaking of stars,
look at this.
-Oh, God.
-Come on, look at this.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Congrats.
-Thank you.
-The cover of "Rolling Stone"?
Come on.
-Thank you.
-It's a great article,
by the way, in here.
And what I liked
about it is, also,
your sense of humor comes
through in this article.
But I know you
named your kidney.
-Yes.
-You named it
after someone we know.
-Right. So, I got
a kidney transplant
a couple of years ago,
and as a way of coping,
I thought I would name it.
It's weird, I know, but I did.
And I named it after
Fred Armisen.
-Yeah, so Fred Armisen
is the name.
Any -- Why?
-Because I love "Portlandia"
and I love everything he does.
And so I'm like, "Hey,
watch Fred, guys," you know?
-Fred Armisen.
And does Fred Armisen
know that he --
-Yeah, he sent me flowers.
I was so excited.
-Is that right? Did he really?
He's actually super-fun.
-Yeah, I heard he's awesome.
-You should hang out with him.
Can we talk about
"My Mind & Me?"
[ Cheers and applause ]
The single is out now.
And fans love it.
And fans are all going on
the socials,
"Hey, does this mean there's
going to be more music?"
-Mm-hmm. That's accurate.
-There is going to be more?
-Finally.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Finally.
-I love that!
-I'm just -- I'm so used to
writing sad-girl songs
because I'm good at that.
But I'm ready to have some fun,
and I think people
are going to like it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, I can't wait.
Alright, good.
So you're in the studio
now and working it?
-Yes. I'm actually doing
it here, which is awesome.
-Oh, really?
It's all happening.
Yeah, I know,
we're all part of it.
I loved the documentary.
-Thank you.
-And, man, oh, man,
I loved that you did it.
I loved that you just kind of
let it all out there.
And when did you start
filming that?
-About six years ago --
seven years ago.
-Seven years ago?
-Yeah.
And we kind of went through
all the different phases
of my life from, you know,
getting diagnosed
and doing all the
things I had to go through.
-Ooh! It's rough.
-Yeah, it is.
I'm not going to lie.
I can't watch it.
And to be honest,
I was scared to release it.
But I knew that being honest
and completely transparent was
what I want to be known for.
I don't want to be
an unattainable thing.
I want people to know that
it's not just you
and that they're not alone.
-Yeah, that's exactly
what I took from it.
Absolutely.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you.
-You do a lot for mental health,
and I know you actually visited
The White House.
and met with the President
and the First Lady.
-Yes.
And we discussed mental health.
Now, I mean,
that was just a conversation.
I hope that there's more
that's going to be happening.
But it was really incredible to
be there with a bunch of
young people,
discussing mental health
and the crisis that we're in.
-Not only the documentary
shows you performing
and writing songs and recording,
but it's like the touring
and also all
the charity work you do,
it's just a lot for one human.
And that's what -- I mean,
it's a lot, what you do.
-I know. I don't --
-Great things.
-Yeah, I don't know how
I do it sometimes.
I'm really tired.
-Yeah.
But it's amazing that you do.
And you give.
And then, when, you do travel
to Africa and you go,
"Hey, I feel great when
I do these things."
And that's another good message
I think people
can take from this, too.
Like, when you do give
and do something for charity,
you feel good.
-Completely.
I feel like I have a purpose.
And, in some ways,
I feel selfish
because I want to do more.
But I do know that I won't stop
this fight until the day I die.
I think mental health
is incredibly important
and should be focused on.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-My favorite part --
Also, by the way, I'm in it.
My voice is in --
-I know.
-That's not my favorite part.
My favorite part is
when you go to your hometown,
where you grew up,
and you go to your house
where you were raised.
-Yes.
-And you have the home videos.
And you're still so cute.
-Oh, thanks.
-But you go to your home
and you're like,
"Oh, I remember this and that."
And it's changed.
-Oh, yeah.
-But then you go,
"Hey, I think I wrote on
the back of this --"
Is it a door or a wall?
-Yes, I did. It was a mirror.
-It's a mirror.
And he actually still has it.
-Yes, he does.
-And you wrote,
"Cole Sprouse" with a heart.
Did you have a crush on
Cole Sprouse?
-Yes, I did.
And my first kiss
was his brother.
-What?!
[ Cheers and applause ]
What?! Dylan?
-On TV. On TV.
-Oh, it's --
You kissed the wrong Sprouse?
-They wrote it
in the script that way.
-Oh, okay. It was part of the --
-It was the show, yes.
-Oh, "Suite Life
of Zack & Cody."
-Yes.
-Okay, so, you went on there.
But why didn't you do
the scene with Cole?
Were you bummed, secretly?
-Oh, I can't say that.
That isn't what it was.
I think I felt much better
that it wasn't him,
because I think I would
have probably been an idiot.
-He was the love of your life.
-He was the love of my life.
-He was the crush.
-He was.
-I want to read some reviews on
the documentary, by the way,
if you want to plug your ears.
-Yeah, just a little bit.
-Yeah.
-"Sincere and soul-bearing,"
"New York Times."
"Selena Gomez: My Mind & Me"
explains much about the star,
the culture, and movement,"
"Wall Street Journal."
"Rolling Stone" said
"profound and powerful."
And it's 97% fresh on
Rotten Tomatoes.
It's a hit, bud.
-Thank you.
-It's cool that you did it.
It's really good
that you did it.
For everyone out there,
check it out.
Please take a look.
Here's Selena's new documentary,
"Selena Gomez: My Mind & Me."
Check this out.
-When I first got out,
I didn't know how
I'd cope with my diagnosis.
What if it happened again?
What if the next time,
I didn't come back?
I needed to keep
learning about it.
I needed to take it day by day.
When I was a kid, I was
terrified of thunderstorms.
I grew up in Texas
and I was so scared that
lightning and thunder
would mean a tornado was coming.
But my mom gave me
these books for kids
that explained storms
and lightning and thunder
and basically said,
"The more you learn about it,
the less you're going to be
afraid of it."
And it really helped.
-Selena Gomez, everyone.
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Selena Gomez: My Mind & Me"
is streaming now on Apple TV+.
Sebastian Maniscalco
joins us next.
Stick around, everybody.